les 800 élèves inscrits au lycée
hôtelier peuvent désormais bénéficier
d'équipements dernière génération dans
cet établissement construit en 1981
après cinq ans de travaux en site occupé
le nouveau visage de la structure a été
dévoilé est différent sommes tout
d'abord si effectivement la modernité à
l'animosité l'acoustique le matériel les
équipements
moderne guillaume sur hector disais tout
à l'heure du lycée du xxième siècle tout
à fait cela et
donc au service de la réussite de nos
jeunes et moins jeunes
quand on regarde les chambres de l'hôtel
d'application les salles de restaurant
lorsque l'on voit les cuisines
parfaitement équipés par le conseil
régional
tout ceci c'est un beau partenariat pour
faire réussir nos jeunes oui je crois
qu'ils vont ils sont prêts à aller
travailler après la région ile-de-france
qui a investi plus de 60 millions
d'euros pour cette rénovation étaient
présentes sur place pour l'inauguration
la région est consacrée à un effort
financier significatif pour avoir ici à
lycée d'excellence où les élèves 7 dans
les meilleures conditions sur ces
métiers de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration du tourisme parce qu'on
sait ce sont des métiers d'avenir
je rappelle que le tourisme est la
première industrie française et en
particulier ici à paris et en ile de
france et donc nous avons ici un vrai
bel établissement aujourd'hui dans des
conditions d'études qui sont tout à fait
exceptionnelles pour voir ce lycée
flambant neuf
une journée portes ouvertes est
organisée ce samedi 25 février entre
9h30 et 16h30
l'occasion également de découvrir la
quarantaine de filières proposées par
l'établissement